it's 2021 how many Ford self-driving
cars are on the road and what are they
doing well we're going to start mass
producing a fully autonomous vehicle
what we call a level 4 vehicle which
means it won't have a steering wheel
won't have a gas pedal or a brake brake
pedal and we see the first applications
kind of commercial applications whether
a ride herring or ride-sharing service
and in in major cities so what 2021 is
is where our intent is to holiday do you
imagine the fleet is at that point well
it'll it will start off fairly modest as
as we start you know signing up
customers and also being able to
populate some of the cities with these
vehicles but we see it growing over time
and and and being a very good business
for us and also providing a lot of
societal benefits for folks so you're
doubling your workforce in Silicon
Valley you're investing in four
different technology companies to help
get you there this suggests more of a
go-it-alone approach when it comes to
self-driving cars why take that route
well actually it's we're asking
ourselves three very important questions
when it comes to the development of
autonomous vehicles and in a lot of
different areas one is where do we want
to play second is how do we want to win
and third is what are the capabilities
that we need so when you look at
autonomous vehicles we've been at this
for over ten years so we have a lot of
engineering know-how but as you can see
from some of the partnering we're doing
with some of these great technical
partners we have said in some cases we
can't do it all ourselves so we're
partnering with a lot of different
companies to allow us to realize that
vision of getting fully autonomous
vehicles on the road that said we've
seen you do a lot of small deals rather
than one or two big ones why is that do
you want to avoid sharing the wheel with
another big company not at all we first
off as we think about how we're going
about this we're not in a race to make
announcements what we are in a race to
do is do what's right for customers and
do rights what we do what's right for
our business and so we're looking at the
technical technology roadmap for
delivering fully autonomous vehicles and
seeking out partners that will help fill
in the spaces for us that we've worked
on for the last ten years so we've seen
so many partnerships so many big
investments in the car industry plus the
tech industry you've got GM buying
cruise automation for a billion dollars
investing five hundred million dollars
in lift Apple investing a billion
dollars in DD Volkswagen and get Daimler
and my taxi why haven't we seen you do
deals like that well again we're not in
a race to make announcements we're when
our race to do what's right for you know
as we want to serve our customers are
you open to deals like we we have always
said that we are open to everything
everything is on the table for us but it
has to make as we think about those
things it has to make sense for our
brand it has to create value for our
company and that's the lens in which we
would look through but we talk with
everybody just like everybody else so
how do you imagine getting into the
ride-sharing business or working with a
company like uber without a deal like
that well in some cases we're doing some
some pilots right now we've done some
ride sharing and car sharing pilots for
the last year and a half some with
vehicles some with the shuttles and
we'll continue to do that and at the
same time talk keep talking with others
and see what what makes sense from a
from a business model standpoint in
terms of how can we make a good business
opportunity out of this but also at the
same time fulfill a societal need Google
remains a big and early player in the
self-driving car space why didn't a deal
between Ford and Google work out and
could a deal still happen well we talked
with everybody and as you can as you can
expect those those conversations are
private but again we always run through
the lens of whoever we talk to does it
make business sense for us does it help
build our brand and also is there a
cultural fit as well what do you make of
the fact that Google and Apple are very
much approaching this as you know
building platforms for the car platforms
for potentially self-driving cars rather
than actually making cars well again I
can't speak for Google or whatever Apple
is doing and clearly that's their
approach from the business they have now
I think there's an underestimation here
I think you know a lot of people think
oh well the tech companies will just
come in and
and you know do better than the car
companies listen we respect all of our
competitors but there's the brains of
the vehicle the virtual driver system
and then there's a vehicle platform we
are the ultimate systems integrator and
we've been doing this for over a hundred
years so if that's their approach what
would make it worthwhile for you to get
involved with one of them your point you
know overall as we said is we look at
the technology look at the roadmaps if
there's some things that others do
better than we do we're open to
partnering and just like we've announced
today for new partners now Tesla is very
much focused on a more semi autonomous
model and you know there's a safety
investigation going on related to one of
their crashes in which someone died
using autopilot you guys are focused on
fully autonomous Google is focused on
fully autonomous your car isn't even
going to have a steering wheel why is
that the best way why not go the semi
autonomous well I can't speak for Tesla
and and clearly we're a leader and what
we call level zero through to us driver
assist features features that will keep
you in your lane those type of things
stop you in traffic stop and go traffic
and we're going to continue to be a
leader there and continue to invest when
in level four we have a lot of
confidence and we believe in our plan
that taking the driver out of the loop
is really important because this little
no-man's land at what point do you have
to reengage the driver in a level-3 type
of vehicle we're kind of struggling with
understanding how do you do that
responsibly and timely for the driver
and that's why we're focused on level
four so someday once you get your cars
on the road afford self-driving car
we'll get involved in an accident it
will be rare but it will happen when
that happens who's liable well as we go
forward we have to have a discussion
with
the regulator Z the consumer advocate
groups insurance companies etc and
clearly this is one of the areas that
we're going to have to all work together
to come up with good policies both
regulatory policies but also legal
policies now one of the investments that
you've announced today you're making
with Baidu and allied our company mmm I
spoke to the head of the self-driving
car unit at I do who said they want cars
on the road by 2021 as well will this
investment with Baidu help you get Ford
self-driving cars on the road in China
well let's put some perspective this we
we co-lead the next series of investment
for for Bella dine we were not partners
with Baidu they're just one of the
financial partners there so I wouldn't
read anything more into that but what
about your China strategy or are trying
to strategy we have a good business in
China it's growing and as we think about
mobility solutions there you know we're
thinking about how do we play a role in
that in addition to our core business of
selling great cars and trucks